Hey ...
Hey ! Hahaha...
On t'a ramené un ficus.
Ho c'est gentil, tiens, pose le.
Ça me fait plaisir que vous soyez venus...
*chuchote* c'est normal.
Comment ça va les amoureux ?
On va bien.
La p'tite fait ses nuits, heuuu..
Nan, toi surtout comment ça va ?
Bah justement moi ça va pas super.
C'est pour ça que j'voulais vous voir.
À vrai dire c'est plutôt à Laura que je voulais parler.
*bafouille* Tu veux que je m'en aille, j'vais vous laisser, si...
Non, non, non, reste ça te concerne un peu aussi
Qu'est ce que tu voulais me dire ?
J'ai vu le médecin et... Ça va pas s'arranger.
J'suis en train de perdre la partie...
Et je voulais te demander un service en fait
Oui mais bien sur tout ce que tu veux...
Avant que je parte,
est-ce que tu pourrais...
me sucer la bite ?
Ouais... *étonnement* Quoi !?
Heu, ouais, "quoi" ?
Voilà j'ai fait le bilan de ma vie, j'ai pas envie de partir avec un regret.
Et je me suis rendu compte que quand je vous ai présenté tous les deux,
j'étais pas mal chaud sur Laura en fait.
Nan mais il est hors de question qu'elle te suce la bite hein !
Le prend pas comme sa mec j'suis en train de mourir ...
J'm'en fous de ça, elle va pas te sucer ok ?
Prends du recul deux secondes et essaye de...
Elle va pas te sucer !
Excusez moi, est-ce que vous pouvez arrêter de parler comme si j’étais pas là ?
Quoi ?
Tu peux arrêter de décider les trucs pour moi deux secondes ?
Mais qu'est-ce que tu racontes ? Tu vas pas lui sucer la bite ?
MAIS J'AI JAMAIS DIT QUE J'VOULAIS LUI SUCER LA BITE !!
Je dis que tu n'as pas a décider les choses pour moi !
Bon bah super, allez suce le !
Désolé de vous avoir dérangés hein !
Mais arrête de jouer au con, j'ai jamais dit que j'allais le sucer !
C'est exactement de ça dont je te parlais dans la voiture !
Parce que dans la voiture on parlait de ta liberté de sucer mes potes ?
Nan, on parlait du fait que tu décides des choses à ma place sans me consulter !
Comme le chalet en décembre !
Ok ! Donc partir dans les Alpes et sucer Julien c'est la même chose ?
A vous partez au ski en décembre ?
Mais tu déformes tous mes propos ! Tu sais quoi j'suis pas ta chose !
HEIN ! J't'appartiens pas je fais ce que j'veux ! JE LE SUCE SI JE VEUX !
Ah !! Donc tu veux l'sucer ?
Non, j'ai pas dit ça ...
Excuse moi mais à l'instant tu viens de dire q...
Tu sais quoi ?
Je vais le sucer maintenant en te regardant bien dans les yeux,
pour que tu comprenne que JE FAIS C'QUE J'VEUX D'MA VIE !!
Alors en fait, moi j'avais plutôt pensé qu'on serait que tous les deux, parce que je suis pas très heu ...
J'avais raison, tu veux juste le sucer !
"J'avais raison, j'avais raison" GNAGNA... Mais tu t'entends ? Mais regarde toi tu fais pitié t'es complètement flippé tu veux tout contrôler !
Tu sais quoi ? Tu m'as soûlé ! Julien, sors ta bite !
Non, non t’embête pas je ...
Mais si, mais vas-y Julien sors ta bite allez sors la, puisque c'est "Vincent tout puissant" qui décide !
Oh et puis on pourrait peut-être baiser aussi tant qu'on y est. Ça fait des mois que personne me baise !
Hein ? Ça pourrait peut-être me dépanner !
Excusez-moi, tout va bien ici ?
Monsieur Jobert vous leur avez annoncé la nouvelle ?
J’allais le faire ...
*Rigole / Se moque*
Je suis guéri en fait !
Oh le con, qu'il est con !
T'es con !
T'étais à ça de me sucer devant lui quand-même !
*Rigolent ensemble*
Ha putain c'est trop bien le cancer !
*Musique techno*
Si vous avez aimé ce sketch,
Venez voir le "Golden Moustache Show" au Grand Rex le 22 juin !
Au programme,
Nos meilleurs sketchs, des inédits et du stand-up.
Allez viens on va rire !
C'est dur vous savez...
Je suis une femme, j'ai des besoins.
Je ne comprendrais jamais mon père ...